[Music]
To Understand Venn Diagram We Need To Look At Just Two Sets
A Set Of People Who Like
Soccer A D And G Like Soccer And A Set Of
People Who Like Cricket B C D And G
Like Cricket
How Do We Represent Those Sets Using  The
Venn diagram let s be the set of people who like
soccer it can be expressed using
just this circle we write the elements AD and
G inside it is the one diagram of this
set and let's call the second set C for
a Venn diagram L V  What we need is a circle and we
write the elements b c d and g In
addition it's how simple the concept of a
diagram is but what is the advantage of
drawing a circle and writing the elements
inside it it helps us understand
important concepts union of sets.
And Intersection of Sets How We'll See That
in the Coming
[Music]
Videos